Earlier we looked at querying string valued fields using
the greater than and less than operators. Returning to
our consideration of queries matching string fields. There are
more complicated sorts of queries that you might want to
perform on strings than just equality and inequality. For
example, we often want to look for patterns in
strings. MongoDB supports querying for string patterns using the
regex operator. Regex is based on a regular expression library.
In particular, the Perl Compatible Regular Expressions library.
For more information, I'd encourage you to just Google
for this. So the regex operator allows us
to do regular expression queries in MongoDB. Let's look
at some examples. Now in this collection, city
documents, contain a motto field or at least some
of them do. So as an example of
doing regex queries in MongoDB, let's take a look
at some of the words these mottos contain. This
is a very simple regular expression. In fact, we
don't even need regex to do this one. So
if I do the query this way, I should match
only documents where friendship is the entire string of
the motto. And here we go, friendship. Okay, so now
let's begin to expand this regular expression. What I'm
going to do first is introduce a very simple change.
Now we're looking for all mottos that contain
the word friendship. And friendship can either be capitalized
or not. And so here we have four, where
before we have simply one document. Okay so, now
let's expand this a little bit more. And if
your regex skills are a little rusty, please see
the instructor notes for documentation and pointers to some
tutorials. So let's expand this to include another word.
Okay, so this regular expression will identify all documents
containing a motto with either the word friendship or the
word pride. And either word can be capitalized. Let's
take a look at the actual models themselves. And again,
I'm going to use a projection to make it
a little bit easier to see the mottos. Okay and
we can see that each one of these has
either the word pride or the word friendship in it.
And capitalization doesn't matter. Okay so, that's about all the farther I
want to go with regex queries in this example. The point here is
that MongoDB supports Perl Compatible Regular Expressions. So, you have a lot of
power in what types of queries you can do involving string value fields.